line things up a little bit right here
all right
so in the last video i set up the
scaffolding for the quadratic
approximation which i'm calling q of a
function an arbitrary two variable
function which i'm calling f and the uh
the form that we have right now looks
like quite a lot actually we have six
different terms now the first three were
just basically stolen from the local
linearization formula and written in
their full abstractness it almost makes
it seem a little bit more complicated
than it is and then these next three
terms are basically the the quadratic
parts we have
what is basically x squared we take it
as x minus x naught squared so that we
don't mess with anything previously once
we plug in x equals x naught but
basically we think of this as x squared
and then this here is basically x times
y but of course we're matching each one
of them with the corresponding x naught
y naught and then this term is the y
squared and the question at hand is how
do we fill in these constants the
coefficients in front of each one of
these quadratic terms to make it so that
this guy q
hugs the graph of f as closely as
possible and i showed that in the very
first video kind of what that what that
hugging means now in formulas the goal
here i should probably state what it is
that we want is for the second partial
derivatives of q so for example if we
take the partial derivative with respect
to x twice in a row we want it to be the
case that if you take that guy and you
evaluate it at the point of interest the
point about which we are approximating
it should be the same as when you take
the second partial derivative of f or
the corresponding second partial
derivative i should say since there's
multiple different second partial
derivatives and you evaluate it at that
same point
and of course we want this to be true
not just with the the second partial
derivative with respect to x twice in a
row but if we did it with the other ones
like for example let's say we took the
partial derivative first with respect to
x and then with respect to y this is
called the mixed partial derivative we
want it to be the case that when we
evaluate that at the point of interest
it's the same as taking the mixed
partial derivative of f you know with
respect to x and then with respect to y
and we evaluate it at that same point
at that same point
and remember for almost all functions
that you deal with when you take this
second partial derivative you know where
we
mix two of the variables it doesn't
matter the order in which you take them
right you could take it first with
respect to x then y or you could do it
first with respect to y and then with
respect to x usually these guys are
equal there are some functions for which
this isn't true but we're going to
basically assume that we're dealing with
functions where this is so that's the
only mixed partial derivative that we
have to take into account and i'll just
kind of get rid of that guy there
and then of course the final one final
one just to have it on record here is
that we want the partial derivative
when we take it with respect to y two
times in a row and we evaluate that at
the same point there's kind of a lot of
this is there's a lot of writing that
goes on with these things and uh that's
just kind of par for the course when it
comes to multivariable calculus but you
take the partial derivative with respect
to y at both of them and you want it to
be the same value at this point so even
though there's a lot going on here all
i'm basically saying is all the second
partial differential information should
be the same for q as it is for f
so let's actually go up and take a look
at our function and start thinking about
what its partial derivatives are what
its first and second partial derivatives
are
and to do that let me first just kind of
clear up
some of the board here
just to make it so we can actually start
computing what this what this uh second
partial derivative is so let's let's go
ahead and do it this first this partial
derivative with respect to x twice what
we'll do is i'll take one of those out
and think partial derivative with
respect to x and then on the inside i'm
going to put what the partial derivative
of this entire expression with respect
to x is well we just take it one term at
a time this first term here is a
constant so that's that goes to zero
the second term here actually has the
variable x in it and when we take its
partial derivative since this is a
linear term it's just going to be that
constant sitting in front of it so it'll
be that constant which is the value of
the partial derivative of f with respect
to x
evaluated at the point of interest
and that's just a constant alright so
that's there
this next term has no x's in it so
that's just going to go to zero
this term is interesting because uh it's
got an x in it so when we take its
derivative with respect to x that 2
comes down so this will be 2 times a
whatever the constant a is multiplied by
x minus
x naught that's what the derivative of
this component is with respect to x
then this over here this also has an x
but it's just showing up basically as a
linear term and when we treat y as a
constant since we're taking the partial
derivative with respect to x what that
ends up being
is b multiplied by that what looks like
a constant as far as x is concerned y
minus y naught
and then the last term doesn't have any
x's in it so that is that is the first
partial derivative with respect to x and
now we do it again now we take the
i'll
maybe i should actually uh clear up even
more of this guy
and now when we take the partial
derivative of this expression with
respect to x f sub x of x not y naught
that's just a constant so that goes to
0.
2 times a times x
that's going to we take the derivative
with respect to x and we're just going
to get 2 times a
and this last term doesn't have any x's
in it so that also goes to 0. so
conveniently when we take the second
partial derivative of q with respect to
x we just get a constant it's this
constant to a
and since we want it to be the case we
want
that this entire thing is equal to
well what do we want we want it to be
the second partial derivative of f you
know both times with respect to x so
here i'm going to use the subscript
notation over here i'm using the kind of
leibniz notation but here just second
partial derivative with respect to x we
want it to match whatever that looks
like when we evaluate it at the point of
interest
so what we could do to make that happen
to make sure that 2a is equal to this
guy is we set
a equal
to one half
of
that
second partial derivative evaluated at
the point of interest
okay so this is something we kind of
tuck away we remember this this is
we have solved for one of the constants
so now let's start thinking about
another one of them i guess actually
don't have to scroll off because let's
say we just want to take the mixed
partial derivative here where if instead
of taking it with respect to x twice we
wanted to let's see i'll kind of erase
this we wanted to
first do it with respect to x and then
do it with respect to y then we can just
kind of edit what we have over here and
we say we already took it with respect
to x so now as our second go as our
second go we're going to be taking it
with respect to y
so in that case instead of getting 2a
let's kind of figure out what it is that
we get when we take the derivative of
this whole guy with respect to y
well this looks like a constant
this here also looks like a constant
since we're doing it with respect to y
and no y's show up and the partial
derivative of this just ends up being b
so again we just get a constant this
time it's b uh not you know 2 well
previously it was 2a but now it's now
it's just b and this time we want it to
equal the mixed partial derivative so
instead of saying f sub x x i'm going to
say f x y which basically says you take
the partial derivative first with
respect to x and then with respect to y
we want this guy to equal the value of
that mixed partial derivative evaluated
at that point so that gives us another
fact that means we can just basically
set
b equal to that and this is this is
another fact another constant that we
can record and now for c
now for c when we're trying to figure
out what that should be the reasoning is
almost identical it's pretty much
symmetric we did everything that we did
for the case x and instead we do it for
taking the partial derivative with
respect to y twice in a row and i
encourage you to do that for yourself
it'll definitely solidify everything
that we're doing here because it can
seem kind of like a lot in a lot of
computations but you're going to get
basically the same conclusion you did
for the constant a it's going to be the
case that you have the constant c
is equal to
one half
of the second partial derivative of f
with respect to y so you're
differentiating with respect to y twice
evaluated at the point of interest
so this is going to be kind of the the
third the third fact and the way that
you get to that conclusion again it's
going to be almost identical to the way
that we found this one for x now when
you plug in these values for a b and c
and these are constants even though
there's you know we've written them as
formulas they are constants when you
plug those in to this full formula
you're going to get the quadratic
approximation it'll have six separate
terms one that corresponds to the
constant two that correspond to the
linear fact and then three which
correspond to the various quadratic
terms and if you want to dig into more
details and kind of go through an
example or two on this i do have an
article on quadratic approximations and
hopefully you can kind of step through
and do some of the computations yourself
as you go
but in all of this even though there's a
lot of formulas going on it can be
pretty notationally heavy i want you to
think back to that original graphical
intuition here let me let me actually
pull up the graphical intuition here so
if you're approximating a function near
a specific point the quadratic
approximation looks like this curve
where if you were to chop it in any
direction it would be it would be a
parabola but it's hugging the graph
pretty closely so it gives us a pretty
close approximation so even though
there's a lot of formulas that go on to
get us that the ultimate visual and i
think the ultimate intuition is actually
a pretty sensible one you're just you're
just hoping to find something that hugs
the function nice and closely and with
that i will see you next video